leading up to the release of Elden ring
I had fallen out of love with video
games I had played games my entire life
and I think like most people the older I
got the harder it was to really dive
into the world of a game like I could
when I was a kid becoming an adult
sometimes requires you to put your
imagination to the side in order to live
and work in reality for a lot of people
video games are a complete escape from
that reality and whether or not that's
truly healthy it allows people to
connect some of my greatest
relationships have come from those I've
met in video game communities I truly
value my time playing these games with
people I otherwise would not have ever
met and that's a really special thing
for me I fell out of love with gaming at
the start of the pandemic with the
lockdown I obviously started playing
games a little bit too much and relied
on it more than I ever did before and
with the releases of new games that I
was excited for but honestly just fell
short that were blatantly unfair
finished with a full price tag still
attached to it I found myself angry with
the gaming industry as a whole when
eldering was announced I was hyped up
just like everybody else but I was also
terrified I really did not want to see
from software release an unfinished game
and we just have another hyped up
release disappoint us yet again this
game was gonna be it for me if a
developer that I looked up to as the
creator of some of the best games ever
made would also fall into the greedy
fire pit that the gaming industry is
seemingly turning into today I told
myself that I would be done I would no
longer spend my time in money playing
video games but Elden Ring released and
I knew the second I walked out into Lim
grave that I was about to play something
really special then I looked out at this
beautiful view of lorenia lakes and I
knew that this game was going to be
something different then I got to the
capital city and my jaw literally
dropped to the floor then I found redone
and the lead up to his boss fight and
knew that this might have been the best
moment I've personally ever had in
gaming then I find out that getting to
the archery isn't the end of the game
but there's even more to explore to the
North and then even more to explore to
the North and then I found this vast
underground area with many different
branching levels and bosses to discover
I'm sure you're getting my point here
the game just kept going you ever wish
you could just erase your memory and
play a game all over again well I had
this feeling four or five different
times when playing Elden ring I knew the
game was going to be big but I never
thought that a game could be this big
and constantly over and over again
throughout this massive World make me
stop in my tracks put down the
controller and just stare at the screen
I have never played a game that made my
jaw drop from the spectacle I was
looking at more than Elden ring the game
has problems every game does whether
it's balancing of weapons or a steep
increase in the in-game game difficulty
whatever it may be I don't think anyone
can make the claim that Elden ring isn't
absolutely beautiful all of these areas
are stunning and filled with intense
detail that creates a matching style to
basically everything in the game I've
heard some people say that the game just
doesn't look realistic and other games
have better graphics I see Elden ring in
all of its areas as beautiful works of
art like paintings it doesn't need to
look perfectly realistic realistic
Graphics don't make a beautiful game and
it definitely doesn't make a good game
eldenraine clearly went with a style
that matches the gameplay and the story
itself everything in the game descends
my imagination wild with possibilities
of how these areas came to be what
happened here and what could be over the
next Hill the gameplay requires the
player to be curious to look deeper into
the meanings of everything that we can
see the game is so mad massive and full
of interesting content that it could
take us years to connect all of its
themes and to truly understand
everything it's the same feeling as when
you're looking at a painting there could
be many different interpretations of a
painting and I believe what makes a
great painting is for it to have the
viewer of it use their imagination to
try and understand it the meaning of a
painting for one person may be
completely different to another person
that's what Eldon ring does for me it
makes me use my imagination to try and
understand the deeper meaning of
everything that I'm looking at that
feeling holds true in every area of this
game the art style gameplay and even the
story is like a Sandbox what you create
from what you're given is really up to
you and while there is a clear story
that we can follow the choices we make
while we journey through this work of
art is up to us and creates a different
meaning for every player burning the ERD
tree down and becoming the law word of
chaos may be really exciting for one
player and completely terrifying for
another leaving the lands between behind
with Ronnie could have a meaning of
weakness and honestly simp-like behavior
for certain players while other players
may see it as the only true path forward
even the main ending of just becoming
the new Elden Lord may be the only thing
players ever wanted throughout their
entire Journey while for others they
paid attention to the corruption
throughout the world and would do
anything to avoid becoming the Elden
Lord but all of this depends on your
playthrough your journey throughout the
game as a player and who you are as a
person molds the game for you no other
game has made me feel this way no other
game has given me that childlike Wonder
of immersion within my imagination like
Eldon ring has I've made many videos
about this game since release and if you
haven't noticed yet I like to theorize
on the deeper meanings of the game more
so than the actual facts presented in
the game the facts are important so we
can understand what really happened
within the game's story but just like in
life the facts presented may have
different meanings depending on who's
looking at it and that's what I really
like to dive into Elden ring may not be
the best game ever made in fact it's not
even my favorite Souls game that for me
goes to bloodborne but I think it's safe
to say that for more reasons than just
the graphics Elden ring is the most
beautiful game I've ever played and
honestly thank you to from software for
creating this world and not falling into
the gaming industry Norms that we're
seeing more and more of if there was
going to be a time for from software to
fail it was with Elden ring but I
believe they definitely met and exceeded
all expectations and for myself it
revitalized my love for gaming it gave
me hope that there are developers out
there who aren't just looking for a
quick cash grab and are okay with
releasing a fully priced unfinished
product to their player base or some
remake of a game we played a decade ago
the other part of this is that the bar
has now been raised for other developers
by a lot Elden ring was extremely
successful more so than even from
software predicted I think gamers in
general played eldenring and realized
that they were given something they
haven't seen in a while a Finnish game
with a lot of effort and love put into
its design it showed other developers
that if you just create a good game that
it will sell they don't need to follow
the industry Norms they just need to
create something they care about and put
enough time into to actually finish and
I'm not saying I'm gonna play Alden ring
for the rest of my life it's definitely
not a perfect game but just like a
painting it doesn't have to be perfect
for me to go back look at it from time
to time and enjoy the beautiful world
that it presents and I can just dive
into its world use my imagination and
just have fun like I used to when I was
a kid thank you for watching and let me
know how you feel about the game I'm
planning on creating a a lore series on
many different areas of the game and the
deeper meanings of items landmarks and
characters that we can find in each of
those areas let me know which area you'd
like to see first make sure to subscribe
as we're getting really close to 100 000
subscribers that would be an absolute
dream come true for me and go follow my
twitch where I'm gonna start learning
the speed run for Eldon ring it should
be a good time with all that said I'll
see you in the next video take care